pedro juan as neto responsable numérique
du mouvement république souveraine
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors techtoc appartient au
groupe chinois bright death mais son pdg
est américain à ce que les accusations
d'espionnage en faveur de pékin sont
fondées selon vous alors dans l'histoire
les présidents américains sont les
champions pour parler d'un risque majeur
sur la sécurité nationale des états unis
on se souvient de ronald reagan avec le
nicaragua qui était quasiment présenté
comme puissance militaire pour envahir
les états unis le nicaragua on se
souvient de george walker bush avec
l'irak
présentée comme la troisième armée du
monde présentant aussi un risque majeur
est donc effectivement aujourd'hui
parler d'un risque majeur pour une
application utilisée par des adolescents
ça paraît un peu spécial on est
typiquement dans l'administration trump
qui fait du trump isme puisque hockey
récemment effectivement des chercheurs
en sécurité ont montré qu'ils avaient
des failles sur la question de la
confidentialité par rapport à
l'application tik tok
mais comme on en démontre régulièrement
sur toutes les applications faisant
réseau seraient tous les réseaux sociaux
serre que ce soit facebook twitter
instagram et c'est donc effectivement
les problèmes sont récurrents sur ce
type de plateforme de protection des
données personnelles
mais y'a rien d'alarmant et concrètement
on a du mal à percevoir qu'est ce que
les services secrets chinois pourraient
exploiter dans du contenu d'adolescents
qui généralement se consomment des
contenus totalement commerciaux c'est
plutôt dans une exposition de leur corps
que on va dire un mouvement
révolutionnaire larvée par les élus
américains accusent également tic tac
d'être un outil aux mains du parti
communiste chinois destiné à interférer
dans les élections d'autres pays
notamment les états unis vous pensez
quoi de ces accusations alors
concrètement ils reprennent l'argument
qui a été utilisé beaucoup
par rapport à la campagne de donald
trump qui était l'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux en particulier du
scandale du scandale cambridge analytica
qui était à son propre profit de
l'élection de 2016
donc aujourd'hui effectivement tik tok
et ans appartenant à des chinois c'est
l'ennemi facile donc on va dire et à ce
réseau social qui pose problème en
sachant qu effectivement il ya un
contentieux entre les utilisateurs de
tik tok et donald trump qui n'est pas
forcément on va dire un vrai
militantisme politique mais lors du
meeting de tulsa en le 20 juin
effectivement les utilisateurs de tik
tok se sont massivement mobilisés pour
réserver des places et donc le meeting a
été un fiasco puisqu'il était
entièrement vide et m'a presque
entièrement vide et c'est vrai que là
dessus je pense que les autorités
républicaines ne comprenant pas ce
phénomène parce que concrètement il faut
être dans cette génération là pour
comprendre cet outil ils voient bien sûr
la mainmise du parti communiste chinois
ce qui me paraît on va dire très étrange
puisque pour un outil qui serait sous ma
mise pays étrangers mettre en avant la
culture américaine puisque concrètement
90% des chansons qui sont chantés par
les adolescents sur tik tok sont des
produits purement commerciaux américains
ça paraît un peu spécieux comme argument
alors l'inde a déjà interdit
l'application chinoise pour des raisons
similaires aux accusations dont elle
fait l'objet à washington est ce que tic
toc se retrouverait pas prise au piège
des rivalités économiques et politiques
de la chine
oui si je pense il faut pas oublier qu
est-ce que pastic toc c'est une société
ultra valorisé mais qui en termes de
chiffre d'affaires
ils ne gagnent à ce jour là en 2019
c'était un million de dollars en chiffre
d'affaires ils ne vivent que par les
levée de fonds c'est aussi taper sur tik
tok s'est tapé sur quelque chose qui
m'adorent ne crée pas de dommages
commercial pour les sociétés du pays
d'ailleurs on le voit avec les états
unis
donald trump tape sur huawei tape sur
tik tok maintenant mais jamais sur apple
qui google qui produisent tous
leur téléphone en chine c'est à dire que
ça dérange pas qu'on travaille avec
foxconn par contre faut pas que
l'entreprise soit complètement chinoise
donc là dessus on est un peu dans une
hypocrisie il faut pointer un ennemi
alors les républicains et en inde avec
le conflit qu'ils ont à l'heure actuelle
avec les chinois ça devient la chine
les démocrates préfère la russie comme
ennemi favori en sachant que c'est
surtout pour cacher leurs propres
turpitudes
c'est dire qu'il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
dire à une ingérence chinoise via tik
tok sur l'élection présidentielle
américaine c'est à dire mais je pense
que même les auteurs de science fiction
les plus ambitieux n'oserait pas
fragments de la faim pedro guen s neto
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes responsable
numérique du mouvement république
souveraine